hey everybody mr kobe here so i want to
do a makeup lab for those of you who are
not in school so this is a flask
with water and a
a blue chemical called bromothymol blue
added to it now bromothymol blue
is a
acid indicator
so it's blue right now but in the
presence of an acid it'll change colors
and what i'm about to do is i'm about to
use this drinking straw right here and
i'm going to
blow my breath
like that i'm going to blow my breath
through the drinking straw into the
the the flask
and in my breath is carbon dioxide now
carbon dioxide is an acid so after a
little bit of time
the carbon dioxide will build up which
is an acid it'll build up and the
bromethymal blue will start to turn
color at first it might turn to like a
a greenish color so if it's if it's blue
like right now that means there's no
carbon dioxide really in the flask if it
turns a green color that means there's a
little bit of carbon dioxide and if it
goes yellow that means there's a lot so
i'm going to start blowing my breath
right now
so
so you can see after about what was that
15 20 seconds it's kind of turned to a
green color let me keep going for a
little bit
and let me give it one more good breath
okay so you can see the color change
again carbon dioxide is an acid and
bromothymol blue will react in the
presence of an acid and so that's why it
turned colors
so uh now what am i going to do with
this bromoblue and this carbon dioxide
well let's let me pause the video and
i'll show you what's next
okay i kind of did a lot off cameras let
me show you here's the flask that had
the bromothymol blue plus my breath that
i just glued the bubbles in and i poured
a lot of the bromethymal blue solution
into these four
tubes right here now inside tube number
one
there's bromo blue carbon dioxide from
my breath there's a water plant an
aquatic plant by the name of alodia you
can see it kind of floating in there and
for the next 24 hours i'm not going to
expose it to sunlight now right now the
initial color of the solution in there
is yellow green we'll see what it looks
like 24 hours from now
tube number two has bromothymol blue
inside carbon dioxide for my breath you
can see there's also a watery plant uh
the elodia plant
but this one i'm gonna expose for the 24
hours to to sunlight right now you can
see there's a yellow green color on the
inside we'll see what it looks like 24
hours from now
tube number three has bromothymol blue
inside
carbon dioxide for my breath
no alodia and this one i'm going to keep
in the dark in darkness for the next 24
hours i'm not going to give it any
sunlight and you can see again the
initial color is yellow green
tube number four
has bromothymol blue inside carbon
dioxide for my breath there's no alodia
but this one i will expose to sunlight
for the next 24 hours
again right now you can see the initial
color is yellow green we'll see if
there's any color change after 24 hours
so i'm going to go ahead and put the
caps on
and
the ones that are going to be in
darkness i'm going to store them in a
cabinet and the ones that are going to
be
in
sunlight i'll show you them in a moment
okay so here are tubes two and four not
only are they right next to a window
so any sunlight that comes in they'll be
exposed to but i also have them growing
or exposed i also have them exposed to
these two grow lamps here these plant
lights so you can see tube number two
has the water plant lodia in it
tube number four does not now i'm gonna
let them sit for 24 hours
now in one of my cupboards
right here
i have tubes
one and three so again tube one has the
elodea plant but will not receive
sunlight
tube three has the alodia plant but will
not i'm sorry tube three two three has
no plant
and it will not receive sunlight so i'm
gonna close the cupboards right there so
i'll come back in 24 hours and show you
the results
okay so welcome it is 24 hours later the
next day has pat or 24 hours has passed
let me show you the results i've already
gathered the tubes out of where they
were stored
so notice
the initial color of tube number one was
a yellow or green yellow green and it's
still the color inside is still kind of
a yellowish green color so no color
change happened in tube number one what
about whoops what about tube number two
notice tube number two
was initially a yellowish green color
but
the liquid inside has clearly gone to uh
to
back back to being blue in color so a
pretty substantial color change has
happened hopefully you'll be able to
explain why that occurred
tube number three
initially was a yellow green color on
the inside and it is still a yellow
green color on the inside so no real
color change in tube number three
and then tube number four
again no real color change tube number
four started out as a yellow green color
and you can see it is still a yellowish
green color so these are the four
tubes right here
based on your lab handout you should be
able to complete the analysis questions
i'll be here if you have any questions
for help
feel free and come talk to me hope this
was helpful thanks